Speaker 1: We got some very interesting news
yesterday about the American relationship
with Saudi Arabia.
If you've been listening to this show for
a while, you've been watching the show for
a while.
You know that I have been saying for, what,
a decade and a half the United States really
needs to reevaluate its relationship with
Saudi Arabia.
Now we understand why the relationship exists.
There is a sort of general shared interest
in calm in the Middle East between the United
States and Saudi Arabia.
And this relates to oil prices and oil production
and for other reasons.
And that has been a major factor in the relationship
between the U.S. and Saudi Arabia.
Cut to the New York Times yesterday.
Joe Biden vows consequences for Saudi Arabia
after oil production cut.
The article reads.
Angered by the kingdom's decision to team
up with Russia.
President Biden signaled openness to retaliatory
measures, including a halt to arms sales and
allowing price fixing lawsuits.
This is a very good article in The Times by
Peter Baker, and it reads that Biden vowed
yesterday to impose consequences on Saudi
Arabia, signaling a rupture in the relationship
between two longtime allies and a reversal
of Biden's own effort to cultivate the energy
rich kingdom.
This all relates to last week's decision by
Saudi led OPEC opec+.
A Biden staff announced he would, quote, reevaluate
the entire relationship with Saudi Arabia
and expressed openness to retaliatory measures
offered by congressional Dems, such as curbing
arms sales or permitting legal action against
the cartel.
This is as much about the direct relationship
with Saudi Arabia as it is about the Russian
war in Ukraine.
And we have to see whether these are empty,
empty words or not.
Are these empty threats?
Are these just vague promises that will never
become anything?
Or is this something real again?
I did not have particularly high hopes for
Joe Biden when I decided I would support him
over Donald Trump.
He was the obviously correct decision over
Donald Trump for any sane person, even remotely
tethered to reality.
But my expectations were quite muted about
Joe Biden.
And despite a period of about three or four
months, five or six months, maybe even during
which very little that I could point to and
say this is a good thing has happened.
Joe Biden's presidency has really sort of
taken a turn for the better.
And it would be another great thing from my
perspective if Joe Biden were to reevaluate
this relationship.
Consider the reality of Saudi Arabia.
I mean, first of all, funded 911.
Most hijackers were Saudi killed and dismembered
Saudi journalist Jamal Khashoggi.
There has been essentially no accountability.
War in Yemen with massive human rights abuses,
by the way, I mean, with some American support.
The United States hands are not exactly clean
of blood there either.
Important to measure, to mention state sponsored
theocratic misogyny and oppression, although
it has improved slightly over the last ten
years economically supporting Russia in their
war in Ukraine.
This has been an alliance for oil purposes
and for general interest in stability in the
Middle East purposes, and in particular with
the United States.
I mean, listen, is it as fast a move away
from fossil fuels as I would like?
No, not nearly.
But in particular, with the growing priority
of the United States under Joe Biden, much
more so than under Donald Trump of furthering
alternative and renewable energy usage and
getting away from fossil fuels.
There is less of a need, in a sense, to be
cozy with what is a very backwards, dictatorial
state.
So if we were able to detach ourselves from
the I guess we'll call it the teat of Saudi
oil, it's a good thing long term.
Now, the truth is that the global situation
is much more complicated than I'm making it
out to be in this segment.
There are many other considerations.
There are all sorts of triangles in which
you have the United States and Saudi Arabia
and some other country, which are important
considerations as well from a foreign policy
standpoint.
But it would be one of the greatest things
Joe Biden could do to cool that relationship
off.
It's been something I've been calling for
for a very long time now.
In the short term, the problem is that this
action by Saudi Arabia will cause energy prices
to go up.
And if Joe Biden did indeed take some substantive,
substantive step to cool that relationship
and to reevaluate, it will probably cause
energy prices to go up even more.
And we're getting into winter where home energy
prices are an important thing.
The increase in energy prices will almost
certainly be used against Joe Biden in 2024.
Republicans will be able to say, Listen, Biden
chose to do this with Saudi Arabia and this
made everybody at home energy costs more and
gas you all the there.
There's no doubt that Republicans will try
to do that.
It's easy to say, well, it's worth it anyway.
Well, for some people, it's an extraordinarily
difficult situation to have an increase in
gas prices or home energy prices, home heating
prices, etc..
That will be in effect and it will be they
will try to use it against Joe Biden.
At some point, the decision has to be made
to back away from this absolutely horrifying
relationship with Saudi Arabia.
And I always say there is no better time than
the present.
If you disagree with me, let me know.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
And we'll be back after this very short break.
The David Pakman Show is an audience supported
program different than corporate media.
Our primary funding source is people who listen
to the show, people who watch the show.
And to that end, I would love for you to get
a membership at join PAC Mint.com.
We do an extra show every day for our members
called the Bonus Show.
Alex Jones hates the bonus show.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else who makes
money to fund themselves as bad.
Speaker 1: Well, yeah, make money in order
to fund the show.
Alex, there's nothing wrong with that.
You can use the coupon code.
Big voting 22 to get yourself a tidy little
discount off of the cost of membership.
You also get the show without commercials
6 hours before everybody else.
Every single weekday.
Pretty good perk, I must say.
Join Pacman dot com